Maybe chimpanzee.
Yeah.
That was gonna be like some Disney thing.
I'm like,
holy cow.
What movie was that?
Literally called chimpanzee.
Who?
Is it?
A documentary?
Yeah.
Like I didn't realize
chimps did calculator.
Cruelty.
Yeah,
right.
Well,
we know better because we've advanced,
but if we hadn't,
we'd be like,
man,
I don't want to fucking live in a house.
I like the champ.
Why his brow chimp ways to go?
This is it,
man.
Chimp life.
I'm now,
but we in a way to the AI
might be like those chimps.
I don't know how much do
we think about chimps?
Not much.
Very little.
These chimps are at war.
I saw that David Attenborough documentary
on Champs when they were eating those
call bus monkeys and ripping them apart.
I go,
Oh,
this is why people were so crazy.
We came from that thing.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
But I got a better philosophy.
They like swingers.
Yeah.
They really are.
They just seem to resolve.
Everything was sex.
The only rules they have is
the mom won't bang the Sun.
That's it.
Okay.
They're good women,
good women in the community.
Everybody else.
Just banging it out.
Yeah.
I haven't seen the winova movie.
Well,
they're disturbing just at a zoo,
at the zoo.
Just constantly going.
Constantly fucking,
yeah,
and they don't care.
Gay,
straight,
whatever.
Let's just fuck it.
These labels
I haven't seen when I was at a zero.
That's probably not on the PGA section.
I don't think they have them at many zoos.
We've looked at that before too.
I think that's a thing that they'd be
like to keep regular chimps at zoos.
Cause Bonilla was just always jacking off.
What's that they have in San Diego?
Really interesting.
Probably separate them.
I mean,
how many other in a cage,
it's going to be pretty intense.